hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play underhell
so you guys told me that the only horror
things that happen in here happen in
this here house so I'm going to be here
you said I should stay in the house I'll
stay in the house all right it's not a
big deal whatever don't also said like
going the closet or something either way
I'm not exactly sure what - it's I don't
want to go in there why not yes I do
shut up you don't know me anyway oh this
closet alright why is that life still on
okay so I'm not exactly sure what - it's
packed
cuz I've been in here before I think I
might be waiting for the Sun to go down
not exactly sure anyway
oh oh that doors still locked
eh no surprise there was that hello no a
bathroom with no sink how disturbing hmm
Oh who left the fridge open Wow who left
the freezer open let's see what sleep
clever an old grimy old stove so far
nothing scary new her diary I do not
read read that already yeah see there's
been a month and your father not happy
Jessica helping me out I really can't
help him maybe one day I'll show it nah
blub well it's car
don't know what that was so you can't
believe it's happening entire country's
shaking Oh September 11th basement I
want to go to the basement what's this
Oh huh hey look let's see ah diaries
page let's see yeah she it's all this
then who's that handsome fellow saved
well huh question mark
this house is your home everything you
need is here remember to answer the
phone each time it rings well you're not
the boss of me if you want to start a
chapter you must go to the truck yeah
yeah okay alright alright alright I get
it I get it I got it let me out let me
out let me out go check the mail okay
that's a good idea
hmm what what yeah alright how
suspicious if you want to go to sleep
you can use the bed at night
next time you'll start the house you
will wake up in your bed okay I have to
go to work not don't that's a lie
there are many locked doors and
mysteries in this house at every locked
door there is a key to every mystery an
answer it's up to you to find them okay
Don and done I was boring who narrated
that one truck keys could chunk oh no
this one hi anything in here let's see
little cop is out there turn ding dong
ding who is that I see you sparkles
is that what is that I see a sparkle
give me what duh
Oh what's this this a remote no that's a
key this is a key this looks like a key
huh a key in a piano ha ha ha donk what
about that work dark turn
dong okay let me try the upstairs maybe
it goes there dong dong ding ding ding
no okay maybe not maybe that's a lie it
is just if dirty dirty lie everything
don't ding ding dong oh okay all right
so nothing there so anything in here
there was no key
what is this supposed to be anybody know
out there anybody want to tell me what
this is supposed to be because I sure
don't know you have to be getting darker
outside hopefully more things won't
happen at night but for now I seem to be
that Sun actually going down let's stare
at it for a few seconds I don't know hmm
I can't even go outside
what kind of stupid house do I live in
where I don't even control what's going
on good thing I'm not superstitious
blablablabla alright seems about it
maybe I could play on this old hoop do
yeah okay
maybe I can get back here this way
swanky nope no what what the hell is
that
hmm and I know maybe I'll try going to
sleep leaving the front door wide open
ah I want to get in what the tiny metal
piece from the piano has been moved to
the inventory table well tell me what it
is besides just a tiny piece of whatever
god you're so unhelpful oh hello
okay so what do I do about that well
maybe I can oh well ever I have a
strange idea that might probably not
work I'm going to use this on the gate
to the back door cuz that makes sense
shut up it's an idea okay
I'm gonna try to go to sleep oh no the
mail I knew oh let me try the mail tang
iron and dear mr. Jake I feel you
remember me married downs Hill team
rescued would have killed me need your
help
next week the trial begins call me at o2
5 ok that number okay so I got a caller
that what I'm supposed to do what the
hell was that
what hey why is it thick hey where'd it
go what doc don't come on let's just
banish hopefully he'll return to the
table I don't know what that was all
about anyway can I call her no can't do
that either
fine I'll go to bed gah
hey jiminy Christmas gah it's so daytime
well how do I make it nighttime oh it's
going down so slowly okay I take a nap
maybe on the couch or something Jesus oh
let me sleep I'm so here stop doing just
sick tricks mr. mug and get out of here
Oh oh yeah okay well I don't know what's
going on you guys taught me to stay in
the house you didn't tell me that
nothing would happen
[Music]
mm-hmm yeah okay they're the tiny middle
piece got moved so uh yeah about the
horror show that's supposed to be
happening right now it's back
nah I don't know Clank think lanky yeah
I I blame myself
Oh
okay maybe not maybe this was a bad idea
I'm certain to think this was a bad idea
I don't know why but things just became
infinitely creepier why did everything
go purple oh man
everything looks slightly more sinister
now okay
perfectly normal nothing uh bad
happening here well this looks weird
tiny metal piece okay move back yeah
whatever
dumpster-diving seriously what's going
on here
all right raisin that up stairs I
suppose what was that what is that what
was that
oh is that hey don't be like that
okay so I'm just put that go in the
closet at night that's right maybe in
here okay this seems perfectly normal
why is everything purple sir ah
Oh God
assist the clock downstairs I'm not
gonna go to sleep yet just in case you
know something bad happens that I'm
supposed to expose myself to see you let
the clock strike at midnight
yeah that sounds like 12 I don't know
huh all the phone I'm supposed to answer
right hi what sucks okay bro sounds good
bro glad all my bros are there for me
so uh about that I think I'll stick
around here for some reason that I'm
like contractually obligated to scare
myself three times a day are you guys
cuz I love you all so much
okay the rest of the pages are missing
so don't see anything else happening ah
maybe it's all past I bet there's
nothing really scary that's supposed to
happen anyway
I don't want to go in there I bet I do
mmm seriously like maybe I'm just
supposed to stay in here oh what's that
there's an attic on the attic I think
there's a basement too but I can't get
in there either ah interesting
nope nothin nothin nothin whole lotta oh
hey batteries oh the sun's rising
already oh come on
well I guess that's all there is to it
unscary having in here I can throw it
away what are you talking about I'm
gonna throw this the heck away get this
out of my mind I'm gonna throw it away
so hardcore like you don't even know man
you don't even know oh it's it's up what
up pink right goodbye yeah Oh Ling let
me feel a on the piano also ding dong oh
it's over okay sorry sorry if that was a
tender moment that I just wrote for you
no yeah no okay all right anyway that
probably invoked the wrath of her evil
ghost so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
sit here I'm out wait till night again
cuz I'm not gonna make you guys wait til
the next episode oh no I'm gonna watch
this I'm gonna concentrate so hard that
time is gonna accelerate forward boom
I'm back okay it's not quite nighttime
yet but something interesting happened
that I think requires your attention
this door opened and I don't know how I
picked up this picture here the one that
I can't Oh can't bear to look at and for
some reason that that upstairs door
opened like I ran up and as soon as I
got up to the top floor it closed on me
again so I don't know what that was all
about and either way I would probably
nothing
probably so I'm just gonna on my
accelerate time again here we go boom
we're back okay no need to accelerate
that bar the phone's ringing hang on a
second damn right yeah oh yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
okay uh hell is that tell my attacker
okay I have an idea to make the ghosts
angrier
no there's a way maybe that'll do summer
or maybe I'm actually just trying to get
rid of the ghost and now the ghost isn't
gonna be as I won't throw that in the
guards okay I'm gonna put it up by my
bed what was that
who's out there I really want to know
why that door open when I picked up this
picture I don't know
take that find it off again
whose are locked for like two seconds
I'm gonna put this right by my bed yeah
haunted book there we go that looks good
right it's not a real I can't pick that
up okay whatever well now as we await
another night of solitude and despair
sleeplessness and rambunctious Ness I
don't know hey look a box can I throw
this away I'm just gonna try to throw
away all these crappy memories I have of
this so-called ghost does non-existing
ghost rubbish you're gonna do another
memoir whenever I throw this away dang
dang dang okay turn in the garage at
night
Jesse's in these well I got a flashlight
now that's something yes all right I
don't know what it box for fine nothing
Rogers had big waste of them
again the dingdong Inc all right I don't
know I don't know guys like what am I
supposed to do to call the what the what
the what the what the know what though
what what what happened what oh the box
no good mock it back
Liz their stuff right ah no no it's
going in a trance it's going in the
trash
no I won't have any of this again dang
dang dang dang dang all right let's see
if it's back upstairs again that would
be frightening
I suppose it's back hi why is it back
huh it all starts pretty slow doesn't it
haunted blocks and all that you're going
in the trash I'm taking out the trash
other cliche turned and and turn saved
again
is it still gonna be in there I bet it
is
burn okay so that's weird
also this picture here don't know what
to do about it though mmm maybe if I put
this picture back where it was open no
the Sun is rising damn it okay all right
so um I'm gonna keep this obviously
going it saves automatically so um let
me know if there's anything that I need
to do to make the scares come about
because I'm trying everything I can
there was that haunted box turned in
good god okay and um so I know just let
me know in the comments below
I'll be reading so thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye